stephen riker um
your students are returning to uh the
campus that's in andrews this week uh
it's this week that triggered a fresh
wave last year what's um what are you
doing on campus to make sure we don't
have a repetition
well there are multiple measures that
are going on in all universities um
across scotland for instance there's
very clear advice on the need to keep
people safe on the need to have testing
need to have vaccination um
very clear messaging on the need to
behave responsibly so you don't put
others at harm so i think at least in
scotland and i can speak for scotland
because i i sit on the recovery group
for universities in scotland um every
university has a very comprehensive plan
about the return um
over the next few weeks although
actually in scotland most people have
already got got back when when you talk
about what's happening often it's very
anglo-centric and you forget scotland
i i could never forget scott and
professor riker but i just want to be
absolutely sure that you feel confident
that we're not going to
uh have the same problems that we've had
in the past you feel you feel confident
about that at the moment oh i mean
there's huge uncertainty i mean simply
put we don't know what's going to happen
and that's true not just in universities
but more generally as um you know as
schools of returning um they've again
they returned a while back in scotland
and we've seen a spike in infections in
young people now the data is beginning
to come through in england people
returning to university people returning
to the workplace people returning
indoors because of uh the when uh with
the sorry
uh
getting organized uh because of the
weather um all these are factors and we
can't know absolutely but we um we have
to be careful
what we do
yeah well we just we discussed all of
those questions actually with the
scottish first minister uh last sunday
and um it's clear that there's a
slightly different point of view you
yourself have been pretty critical of
the government the um
of uh the johnson
for
administration
underpinning its legal measures with
behavioral
uh science and behavioral nudges um
are you supportive of what they've done
this week on travel restrictions
i think the example of travel
restrictions is an example where we had
a dysfunctional system
dysfunctional because of the
all the mess around getting
pcr tests all the different companies
charging absurd rates not providing a
service and so on and they've
responded not by improving the system
but by abandoning it entirely and i
think that's a pity i do think we need
pcr tests
because everybody always said that
lateral flow tests whenever what we call
green light tests test to say you're
safe and therefore we can uh you you can
act as if you don't have the virus what
they do is they pick up asymptomatic
cases and very very valuable in that
regard i think it would be far
preferable to keep pcr tests but to
improve the system and and to do them
through the nhs so i think it is
increasing risk i think it does limit
in fact it stops our ability to trace
different variants and increases the
probability of of infected people coming
into the country so i think it has
increased the risk quite frankly and i
think we should have improved the system
rather than by and large abandoning it
okay so
so you're against the dropping of the
pcr test do you think
that the
decision to offer booster jabs to
everyone uh is actually a good
step forward well rather than doing this
piecemeal let me give you my sense of
the overall direction of travel we
should have because
if you remember back to last year 21st
of september last year sage made a
recommendation that we need to put
protections
in place in order to
avoid the pandemic getting out of
control and the government ignored that
they ignored it for nearly two months
the pandemic got so far out of control
that as always happens if you wait and
things get out of control you have to
impose greater restrictions which is why
we had a non-christmas and such an awful
winter and spring on the 8th of
september this year
sage again made the point that actually
we're in real danger we can't be certain
but we're in danger of things running
out of control and rather than having to
put in place severe restrictions later
let's do sensible things now and the
good place we're in largely due to the
vaccine is that in order to get things
under control if you combine the vaccine
not with stringent lockdown but with
moderate protections and support for
people then you can bring even the delta
variant under control and that's been
shown in a range of countries it's been
shown in israel it's been shown in
denmark it's been shown in singapore so
what i would do is not restrict the
public not lock down the public but
increase the protections for the public
and let's take just one very simple
example
when we talk about safety we often focus
on the individual the individual must
get vaccinated it would be far more
effective i think to make sure that
environments are safe that the pubs and
the clubs and so on that we go into have
got proper coverage standards so why
don't we have a proper licensing system
exactly the way the same way that we
license kitchens to make sure that they
don't
um to keep us safe so protections not
restrictions protections and support
along with the vaccine that will keep us
safe very briefly
there are nearly six million people who
either because they couldn't be bothered
or because they are actively opposed to
it have not been vaccinated very briefly
is there any way that you can see to get
those people jabbed
yes first of all as you say most people
who are not vaccinated aren't vaccine
hesitant or anti-vaxxed they simply
haven't got around to it so make it
easier for them by bringing vaccine
stations into schools into universities
into workplaces make sure that people
can have paid time off to get vaccinated
so make it easy bring the vaccine to the
people that's number one number two is
to give clear and consistent information
as to why vaccines are important and if
you spread a message implicitly or
explicitly that infections don't matter
and people are going to think why should
i get vaccinated and the third and the
most important is amongst those who have
doubts don't treat them as fools don't
treat them as the enemy don't push them
away don't push them into the hands of
the anti-vaxxers build trust show
respect listen to people address their
concerns um and as i say win them over
trust is absolutely critical and that's
one of the things that government has
forgotten build trust don't distrust the
public